da willst du meine damen und herren
herzlich willkommen hier heute endlich
mal wieder zu einer neuen episode ebay
fans mit hits von und zuletzt whisky ja
klar wer kennt ihn nicht whisky peter
laufer antikes cover bord und da preis
verhandelbar akkus finde ich ihn nie
mehr das will ich kaufe äußerst seltene
drei kapsel erdnuss und das ist das foto
schauen wir uns mal die beschreibung an
verkaufe hier eine enorm seltene 3
kapseln erdnuss ist wie auf dem bild zu
sehen noch in ihrer original natur hülle
verpackt sie ist für sammler gedacht die
vielleicht auch sportwagen sammeln
edelsteine und so weiter
ja jeder sportwagen sammler werden
bestimmt auch an deiner 3 kapseln
erdnuss interessiert als nächstes
verkauft jemand eine tasche und zwar die
louis biotonnen tasche ich glaub das
heißt wie tor und nicht biotonnen
nintendo hypothetischen wer hat denn so
viel langeweile dass dem sohn des
scheins mars mit seinem essen alter
nimbus 3000 mit licht und klingel
verkehrt sich ja bitte löscht ein für
eure liebe ja genau das sind 35 ikea
stifter die ich heute alle geklaut habe
ich möchte sie wieder loswerden und habe
mir überlegt sie hier zu verkaufen der
preis ist auch fair als er hat die
stifter geklaut verkauft sie dann
allerdings für 55 euro egal gibt es
kostenlosen jedem ich verkaufe 1 dicken
meerschwein jäger das tier hat auch
gefühle gut die banane
ja ich glaub da brauche ich gar nichts
mehr zu sagen da geht nix dafür deine
mutter bieten nagelknipser für deine
mutter oder schwiegermutter bald ist
muttertag
ja darüber freut sich jede mutter am
muttertag als nächstes verkauft ihr ein
mädchen ihr altes nintendo ds spiel und
zwar trägt dieses spiel den namen barbie
und die drei musketiere in den titel
ihres ebay angebot schreibt sie
allerdings fabi und die drei muskelriss
also wenigstens der preis ist fair
schneemann aus dem jahr 2018 als ich
diesen titel gelesen habe dachte ich mir
erstmal hey wie sieht denn ein
schneemann aus dem jahr 2018 aus also
wirklich applaus für deine leistung das
hier ist das coverfoto vom nächsten ebay
angeboten man sieht schon hey es ist ein
halbes mettbrötchen man nennt sie dann
vielleicht erstmal hey vielleicht
verschenkte er das oder keine ahnung was
neben der schreibt ein halbes
mettbrötchen gegen ps4 via brille oder
galaxy 8 ja klar dass genau gleich viel
wert 200 euro für vision harte nacht
hallo ich hatte eine richtig
durchtriebene nacht so etwas passiert
mir nie ich habe leider alles folge kotz
und das muss nun wieder sauber gemacht
werden da ich in einer wg wurde und
wirklich absolut kein bock habe 200 euro
für sauber machen geht ganz schnell ist
aber wieder licht tut mir leid ich
glaube das angebot ist von sandra im
nächstenliebe angebot verkauft jemand
einen samsung galaxy a3 bastler
freundlich und denkt sich da erst mal
hey was heißt bastler freundlich sind
ein paar ersatzteile dabei et cetera pp
das ding jetzt einfach nur noch zum
drittel vorhanden
also da hat jeder was da spaß dran
verkaufen das spiel udo becker ich habe
überhaupt nichts dagegen wenn sich leute
irgendwie verschreiben wenn ihrer ebay
anzeige et cetera pp aber da ist sogar
ein bild mit dem richtigen namen des
spiels sein letzter großer pickel am ohr
schmidt helmut das ist das foto man
sieht schon dass es ein zwei euro stück
ist er verkauft dieses zwei-euro-stücke
allerdings für 163 euro guter deal
bruder als nächstes verkaufte jemand
einen game of thrones meerschweinchen
auf einem karotten turnier mit biete ich
mein meerschweinchen an seitdem die
letzte staffel von game of thrones
gelaufen ist dreht das vieh komplett am
rad hat sich jetzt einen thron auf
seinem futter gebaut abgabe auf eigene
gefahr könnte bewaffnet und sehr
aggressiv sein
decker was ihr für einen humor hat lego
star wars obi wan kenobi ja das ist ein
jeder der gerne knobloch ist trampolin
drei meter ohne netz und ohne internet
ja ich muss leider absagen beim ein
trampolin sollte schon wlan kabel haben
warmes badewasser ca 120 liter nur 15
minuten benutzt bitte einmal mitbringen
wenn ihr erst bis 11 uhr abholt könnt
ihr es auch vor ort nutzen dresden
wildermann ps die ente ist nur deko und
gehört nicht dazu
ja ich wäre eigentlich vorbei gekommen
nach dresden aber die ente alter wenn
die nicht dabei ist dann komme ich nicht
kommen nun allerdings zum letzten die
bfl für die heutige folge meine lieben
freunde und zwar ist dieser hier
verschenke make up spiegel und man denkt
sich ja schön trasse vielleicht ein foto
davon ja der wahnsinn super foto dpa an
der stadt ihr euch das heutige wird
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch die heutigen
episode ebay fans gefallen hat dann das
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da und abonniert main kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der lupus
[Musik]